[موسيقى]
اذا نبدا جولتنا من تداعيات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا تتوصل الان في بروكسل قمه المجلس
الاوروبي التي تتناوله الوضع في اوكرانيا
ويحاول القاده الاوروبيون خلال القمه
ايجاد توافق على سقف اسعار الغاز ووضعي
تفاصيل لحزمه تاسعه من العقوبه على روسيا
قد القى الرئيس الروسي كلمه امام القمه
اكد فيها ضروره هزيمه ما وصفه بارهاب
الطاقه الروسيه في الوقت ذاتها تاكد
الرئيس الروسي ان بلاده تتعرض لعدوان من
اجل تحقيق اقتصادها وانا العقوبات على
بلاده ادت الى تضخم من قياسيا في الدول
الاوروبيه حسب قوله وهذا ما سنلقي المزيد
على الضوء عليه مع التطورات واخر
المستجدات مراسلنا في بروكسل العبد الله
الشامي
عامر لا في كذلك مراسلنا في موسكو امين
البدايه معك امين ومع ابرز تصريحات الرئيس
الروسي تفضل
[تصفيق]
ماما خلال اجتماع مع اعضاء المجلس المجلس
المشاريع الاستراتيجيه والتنميه في روسيا
بوتين سرد عدد من الارقام التي حققها
الاقتصاد الروسي اا مع اقتراب نهايه هذا
العام في ظلمه وصفه
بالحرب الاقتصاديه التي يشنها الغرب منذ
بدا العمليه العسكريه فوق اوكرانيا من اجل
الحق ضرر كبير بها الاقتصاد قد يؤدي الى
انهيار العمله الى تضخم غير مسبوق كما قال
الرئيس الروسي لكنه قال بان كل هذه
المساعي لم تنجح بفضل ما قال انه تضافر
لجهود السلطات الروسيه ورجال الاعمال
والبنك المركزي وايضا المواطنين وايضا من
خلال بعض الاجراءات والخطوات التي اتخذتها
الحكومه الروسيه وتتمثل في الاساس بالبحث
عن اصوات جديده
لتصدير همم يعني موارد الطاقه اضافه الى
المدفوعات تحويل المدفوعات مقابل الغاز
بالروبل الروسي وبتعامل بالعملات الوطنيه
مع عدد من الدول في تعاملات التجاريه
بوتين طبعا انتقد بشده سياسات الغرب خاصه
فيما يتعلق باسعار بالغاز وهو طبعا يعني
تحديد سقف
يعني الموارد الطاقه الروسيه قال بانه
سيتم قريبا انشاء منصه الكترونيه
لتحديد اسعار الغاز لاوروبا ووصفا سياسه
الاوروبيين في هذا الشان بانها مجنونه همم
بان همم البلاد يعني حقت انجازات كبيره
فيما يخص الاقتصاد وصف الروبل الروسي
اليوم بانه من اقوى العملات فقال بان هو
في الوقت الذي شهدت فيه اسعار المواد في
عدد كبير من دول العالم همم في مارس
وابريل من هذا العام ضلت مستقره في روسيا
وذلك بسبب تلك الخطوات التي قال ان
الحكومه الروسيه همم اتخذتها فلنستمع الى
ما قاله الرئيس الروسي في الجزء الخاص
بما يقول او ما يصفه بتعرض اقتصاد روسيا
همم لحرب من اجل تدميره
كما تعلمون تم شنه عدوان بشكل عقوبه غير
مسبوقه على روسيا كان يهدف بشكل اساسي الى
تحقيق اقتصادنا في وقت قصير وتدمير العمله
الوطنيه من خلال سرقه احتياطياتنا من
العملات الاجنبيه واحداث تضخم المدمر هذه
الحسابات كما رايتم وانا ارى جميعا لم
تفلح رجال الاعمال الروس والسلطات عملوا
بشكل جماعي ومهني حتى استقر الوضع
الرئيس الروسي يتحدث عن حرب اقتصاديه
تتعرض لها بلاده عامر لا في رئيس
الاوكرانيه من جانبيه يتحدث عن ارهاب طاقه
الروسيه كيف يعتزم مواجهه هذه هذا الارهاب
من جانبيه كما وصفهه
نعم ليلى يعني الرئيس اليوم وفي خطاب طويل
دعيني اصفه بالخطاب الطويل امام المجلس
الاوروبي اليوم يعني ناقش العديد من
القضايا وقيام السته اشهر الماضي وسته
اشهر القادمه في هذا الاطار كما ذكرتي سته
اشهر لماذا لانه بعد اسبوع تقريبا سيكون
قد مر سته اشهر على قبول اوكرانيا كمرشح
لعضويه الاتحاد الاوروبي وبالتالي في هذا
الخطاب الطويل حاول الذي نسقي طوال الخطاب
ان يربط مصير اوكرانيا بمصير اوروبا ويثبت
لهم كيف ان كل شيء كل تغيير كل ما قد يطرا
على اوروبا على اوكرانيا عفوا سيؤثر بشكل
او باخر على اوروبا بمعنى يعني تحدث لهم
حتى عن تمكن القوات الاوكرانيه من استعاده
السيطره على العديد من المناطق سواء في
شمال دونيس وشرق كيف او في كرتون وقال
منها اراضي اوروبيه تمكن الجيش الاوكراني
بدعمكم بدعم الاوروبيه من استعاداتها ايضا
تحدث عن ان قدرت الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه على سد الص كلاروسيه اعتبرها
هي زياده وحمايه لاوروبا من ما وصفه
بالارهاب الصاروخي الروسي ليس فقط
لاوكرانيا وانما لكل اوروبا تحدث ايضا عن
ان اي دعم اوروبي للطاقه هنا التي تستهدف
بشكل مستمر انشاءات الطاقه الحيويه هو
ايضا الحمايه لاوروبا لماذا يقول زيننسكي
ليلى بان اذا همم في هذا البرد الشديد
اللي كما تلاحظون خلفي اذا ما دمرت الطاقه
هنا سيكون هناك هجره جماعيه من اوكرانيا
الى اوروبا وهذا يهدد مستقبل اوروبا
وحدودها ايضا حتى ان اتفاقيه نقل الحبوب
التي تم التوافق عليها كما تعلمين في
اسطنبول في تموز الماضي هي ايضا لا اوروبا
فسر ذلك سيسكي الليله بانه انقذ العالم من
مجاعه وبالتالي اذا ما حصل لما جاء في
ستكون او فسيكون جنوب اوروبا
ايضا هجرات جماعيه من القاره الافريقيه
على سبيل المثال بسبب المجاعه التي كانت
ستضرب هذه تلك المنطقه وبالتالي اتفاقيه
هي دعم ايضا لاوروبا وعليه المسكي طال
الاوروبيين طالب الاتحاد الاوروبي من خلال
ثلاث نقاط رئيسيه اذا يمكن تلخيصها بدعم
اوكرانيا هذه النقاط الرئيسيه بدايه واحد
تسليح اوكرانيا مذهى بانواع جديده ومؤثره
وحديثه ومتطوره من الاسلحه لصد العدوان
الروسي كما يقول او على حد وصفه النقطه
الثانيه يريد حمايه للطاقه الاوكرانيه
امداد بالطاقه سواء بالغاز وبالكهرباء
وايضا دفاعات جويه لحمايه منشات الطاقه
الاوروبيه النقطه الثالثه التي اراد ايضا
بها دعم هي موضوع الدبلوماسيه تعليم
الرئيس الاسكي كان قد تقدم بصيغه
الاوكرانيه للسلام كما وصفها مكونه من 10
نقاط اريد منكم ان تدعموها وان تدعموها
وتشارك في القمه قمه السلام العالميه التي
تذكورين دعا لها منذ عده ايام وما زال
يدعو لها العالم وبا ان تكون وسيله لتطبيق
هذه الصيغه الاوكرانيه للسلام كل هذا ذكره
في في هذه الكلمه استمعوا معنا لما قاله
زرنيسك اليوم امام المجلس الاوروبي
ستكون الاشهر السته المقبله حاسمه من
نواحي عديده في المواجهه التي بداتها
روسيا بهذا العدوان العدوان على اوكرانيا
وضد كل واحد منكم لان الهدف النهائي
لروسيا هو ابعد بكثير من حدودنا والسياده
الاوكرانيه اولا يجب هزيمه ارهاب الطاقه
الروسي بجميع اشكاله وثانيا صمود اوكرانيا
في هذا الشتاء انني احسكم على مواصله فعل
كل شيء حتى نتمكن من دعم امدادات الطاقه
لاوكرانيين وثا الدعم العسكري يجب ان لا
يقل عن الاشهر السته الماضيه نحن بحاجه
الى مزيد من الاسلحه الحديثه والمزيد من
الدعم رابعا الديبلوماسيه احسكم على دعم
صيغه السلام الاوكرانيه
خلصوا اذا كلمه سيلنسكي هذا كانت موجهه
للمجلس الاوروبي وانت تقف داخل المجلس عبد
الله حدثنا عن الاجواء عن الطريقه التي تم
استقبال بها ما قاله زليكه
لا يبدو انها الكلمه ربما لا قد الصدى
المطلوب او الذي يتوقعه الاوكران حتى الان
بالنظر الى انه حتى هذه اللحظه رغم مضيئه
الوقت الذي كان مقررا لمناقشه ملف
الاوكراني الا ان هناك خلافات او بمعنى
اخر هولندا تعطل الاتفاق على جزئيتين
خاصتين باوكرانيا او ذالك في ما له علاقه
بملف الدعم الذي سيقدم لها في العام
المقبل مبلغ 18 مليار يورو كان قد تم
اقرارها من كل من البرلمان وكذلك المفوضيه
الاوروبيه هذا المبلغ همم لكي يكون نافذه
او يتم صرفه ويجب ان يوافق عليه المجلس
الاوروبي لكن بولندا تعطله بالاضافه ايضا
الى الحزن الحزمه التاسع من العقوبات ضد
روسيا في هاتين مسالتين بولندا تريد ان لا
يتم استثناء بعض الاسماء التي تطالب دول
اخرى في الاتحاد بازالتها من قائمه
العقوبات في ذات الوقت ايضا تفاصيل لها
علاقه بالدعم الاوروبي قدم لبولندا في ضمن
عدواتها في الاتحاد مقابل ذلك كله بولندا
ترفض او حتى الان تعطل التوافق حول هاتين
النقطتين فيما يخص اوكرانيا وهو ربما ما
قد يؤجل ملف الطاقه الى وقت متاخر من مساء
هذا اليوم وبالتالي حتى الان لا يبدو ربما
ان كلمات زنسكي الذي ذكر في خطابه هذه
النقطه بالتحديد نقطه المبلغ المالي الذي
تم التوافق عليه اي 18 مليار يورو قد لاقت
ربما الصدى المطلوب هناك ايضا تخوفات من
انه اذا لم يتم التوافق اليوم همم قد يتم
تمديد هذه القمه الى يومين الى الغده رغم
انها حتى الان فقط يجب ان او ستنهى اليوم
وبالتالي ايضا المخاوف من ان اا تمديد
الوقت للحديث عن اوكرانيا قد لا يعطي
الوقت اللازم لملف الطاقه الذي كما قلت في
متن الخبر شال من شارع رئيس مجلس اوروبا
تحدث عن تعقيدات وتشبيكات كبيره همم تمنع
ربما التوافق حول الامر وهو ربما قد يلجا
به الاوروبيون الى محاوله الضغط اكثر على
الدول التي تمنع التوافق وايضا ربما اعطاء
مزيد من التنازلات بمحاوله ل- اا يعني
اللحاق بالوقت المتبقي لهذه القمه لكي
يخرج او تخرج هذه القمه الاخيره هذا العام
بتوافقات حول كل من ملف اوكرانيا وملفه
اسعار الطاقه
امين درغامي من موسكو شكرا لكم جميعا